is this the first really big victim of
the writer's strike in Hollywood welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and move
your Channel
[Music]
Metropolis was released in cinemas in
1927. it was a silent sci-fi movie it
was very Grand in scale it was actually
insanely expensive for the time it was
possibly a little bit of a propaganda
movie it was considered to be quite
communist in nature the basic plot if
you've never seen one of the most
influential Sci-Fi movies of all time
was basically that there was a
metropolis a utopian society sat on top
of a very not utopian society a very
poor Society being used and abused by
the wealthy above not a particularly
complicated plot politically considered
very naive at the time a time when you
have to remember that communism was on
the rise and a lot of countries were
very worried about it this film was
actually accused of having very
communist Tendencies to it and well it
might have done but now we look back at
it with very different eyes from a
Sci-Fi point of view we can look back on
it as a Triumph in cinema it was one of
the first really big budget big special
effects movies and it really has stood
the test of time in lots of ways almost
everybody knows images from this movie
people have tried to remake it several
times but always failed but Sam Ismail
from Mr Robot Fame was trying again it's
actually been about seven years since
this project was greenlit it has really
been spinning its wheels for a very long
time but it was about to go into
production this summer it was going to
start filming they'd done a lot of the
casting and they'd even started building
vast sets and when I say vast these were
insanely expensive it was going to be a
really big budget project it was
actually being filmed in a part of
Australia that has a pretty big virtual
entertainment business sector so they
were going to really take advantage of
that when doing a lot of the special
effects this was going to be a big
project for UCP in partnership with
apple but now it's dead
why is a little bit complicated and it
comes from a few different factors one
being that Sam Ismail didn't get the
script done by the second and Main
deadline so currently the scripts were
not complete even though we had seven
years
Sammy
they weren't actually done there was
lots of rewrites lots of problems with
some of the pre-production they had as I
say started to build these vast sets and
apparently they were horrendously
expensive not just to construct more of
them but to actually maintain and keep
ready the ones that had already
constructed
so those are mounting costs on that and
at the end of the day UCP stated that
look we don't know when we're going to
be able to film these costs are mounting
and mounting and we definitely have a
right to strike we may get an act to
strike we're not sure about the
directors at the moment whether they
might end up going on strike even though
we thought that was resolved it might
not be the producers have still got to
start their negotiations at the moment
there is no light at the end of the
tunnel but we're spending millions of
dollars so just a couple of days ago
they informed their Partners at Apple TV
that they will no longer be going ahead
with this eight-part project now for Sam
Ismail this is another big blow I
reported to you guys a few months ago
his Ambitions to do the Battle Star
Galactica TV series have also hit a
brick wall there is very very little
chance they will actually be going ahead
the filming was already supposed to have
started last like November and the fact
that it hasn't really is a big indicator
but my sources that working around this
have said it ain't happening there's no
appetite right now for a big budget
Battlestar Galactica series simply
because the last series was only a
couple of years ago the movie doesn't
look like it's happening that was really
going to be a big part because they were
going to exist within the same universe
if that ain't happening the TV series
ain't happening and it's just an expense
that the people involved don't want
right now
so why do I say that this is the first
big scalp of the writer's strike the
first big project to really go under
because of it well for one the project
was going to cost anything upwards of
300 million dollars which is a lot it
was going to be really a big sci-fi
project loads of special effects it
really had to live up to the
expectations of a movie that was
originally and still considered to be
one of the greatest Sci-Fi movies ever
made from a visual's point of view if
nothing else for this in 1920 the
special effects were insane and the TV
series would have had to have lived up
to that expectation but there have been
lots of other projects canceled because
of the writer strike and not just
because of the right to strike but
because a lot of streaming services have
spent way too much money over the last
five to ten years their budgets have
just gone nuts and they've all had to
rain those in apple though is probably
the exception to the rule but it is
interesting it is actually UCP that have
pulled the plug and not Apple UCP have
informed Apple of their decision not the
other way around
Apple are willing to spend the money
where Amazon Disney
Paramount Etc are desperately trying to
rein in costs UCP seem to be the ones
that actually desperately try not to
spend the money but a lot of the
projects that we've had canceled so far
were either TV series that just weren't
doing that well so this was just you
know the final nail in the coffin or
stuff that was in pre-production but you
know they decided to pull so you know
they'd say look the writer strikes
happened we can't move forward with them
right now let's put a pin in it and
think about it maybe come back to it
later but for the moment it's done
so the right to strike really has
stopped some stuff from getting into
development but it's not really shut
anything down permanently a couple of
projects for example like Daredevil I've
been put on pause filming it started but
because of everything else they've said
look we'll just put it on pause until
this is sorted but they haven't actually
been canceled Metropolis was a highly
anticipated project not just because of
Samus males connection but because it
was based on the original that's been
regularly voted to be the most
influential sci-fi movie ever made
so this really is a little bit of a
shock this really does show the impact
of not just the right to strike but also
the rising costs in Hollywood and the
fact that they just cannot sustain the
spending that they've been doing the
last five to ten years we're not going
to be seeing these big budget projects
anything like as much going forwards
even Netflix are going to have to start
raining in some of that spending I
really do suspect this might be the
first of many
but guys get into the comments to what
you think is this a shame that we aren't
going to be losing this Metropolis TV
series is that something that actually
you would have loved to have seen that
this is actually based on a basic
premise that is still just as real today
as it was in the 1920s of a rich upper
class taken advantage of a lower poor
class is that really a story of all ages
I'd love to know exactly what you think
so please get into the comments if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification you
know what to do also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you get to see most of our new
videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts and you can even do
a seven day free trial to see what it's
all about so go and check it out as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]